plus aucune raison de ne pas aller
pique-niquer chemin volo corps dimanche
dont une a fait le conseil départemental
propose désormais aux accros du rougail
saucisses et zambrocal de poser leurs
marmites sur les deux nouvelles aires de
pique nique du volcan c'est au niveau de
python sec que s'offre aux
pique-niqueurs ces nouveaux espaces
composé de kiosques de banc de foyers
pour réchauffer ou faire cuire le cas
partenariat dure depuis des années entre
lodève qui est comme je disais tout à
l'heure le principal gestionnaire donc
de la forêt départementaux de magna qui
est propriétaire dont le département en
est propriétaire
et c'est vrai que ce partenariat ne peut
pas se faire parce que nous avons des
agences de l'eau nf qui sont très
impliqués qui ont une volonté d'avancer
sur le territoire et de faire valoir
donc tous ces espaces qui est comme
gelée dit de la compétence du conseil
départemental
un aménagement de deux cent mille 700
euros qui répond à une augmentation du
public qui fréquentent ce lieu
ce sont donc trois kiosques accompagnée
de bandeaux table et deux places de feu
qui permettent aux familles d'être
confortablement installés pour leur
pique nique dominical principal c'était
déjà de venir ici j'ai trouvé
l'emplacement qui se trouve le plus plat
possible parce que trois mois si vous
allez à droite à gauche ou verts il ya
des beaucoup de pente donc on peut pas
faire des aires d'accueil
il ya énormément de pente donc on
recherche une zone déjà sur le terrain
qui est la plus plate
une fois qu'on a des limites et une
surface il ya plus qu on les éclaircies
ce parce que comme vous voyez à côté ces
dates du cryptomérias donc c'est des
zones très ombragé donc pour de
l'accueil du public c'est pas très
agréable on sent pas très à l'aise donc
une fois qu'on a des limites et nos
zones on a on a fait les éclaircies en
relevant le couvert végétal
on a coupé les branches jusqu'à 4 5
mètres de haut apprenez coupé décrypte
pour donner que le soleil puissent
pénétrer pour prévoir nos emplacements
de curieuses de tables bancs on a créé
des places de parking pour que les gens
puissent quand ils arrivent ici se
stationner sur ce site on en veut à peu
près 25 places de parking on a trois
kiosques avec une quinzaine de tables
bancs 15 places à feu donc on a une
capacité d'accueil à peu près d'une
centaine de personnes en comptant quatre
à cinq personnes par voiture
autre point très important la
sensibilisation des réunionnais aux
problématiques environnementales
le choix a été fait ici de ne pas mettre
de poubelles volonté du conseil
départemental c'est aussi bien sûr à
travers le plan déchets que nous avons
que nous sommes en train d'élaborer de
mener une réunionnais à réfléchir à
l'assaut à avoir des gestes éco citoyens
et sur chaque site que nous allons
aménager dorénavant on trouvera plus de
poubelles parce qu'il faut que chacun
d'entre nous nous soyons conscients
qu'il ne faut pas polluer donc la nature
dont les déchets que nous apportons nous
les ramenons avec nous nous avons un
geste écocitoyen un geste responsable
l'eau est neuf et son principal
financeur le conseil départemental
comptent à leur actif plus de 350 heures
de pique nique